so what we have here are two different
polynomials p1 and p2 and they have been
expressed in factored form and you can
also see their graphs this is the graph
of y is equal to p1 of x in blue and the
graph of y is equal to p2x in
white what we're going to do in this
video is continue our study of zeros but
we're going to look at a special case
when something interesting happens with
their with the zeros
so let's just first look at p1's zeros
so i'll set up a little table here
because it'll be useful
so the first column let's just make it
the zeros
the x values at which
at which our polynomial is equal to zero
and that's pretty easy to figure out
from factored form when x is equal to
one the whole thing is going to be equal
to zero because zero times anything is
zero when x is equal to two by the same
argument and when x is equal to three
and we can see it here on the graph when
x equals one the graph of y is equal to
p1 intersects the x-axis it does it
again at the next zero x equals two and
at the next zero x equals three we can
also see the property that between
consecutive zeros our function our
polynomial
maintains the same sign so between these
first two or actually before this first
zero it's negative then between these
first two it's positive then the next
two it's negative and then after that it
is positive now what about p2
well p2
is interesting because if you were to
multiply this out it would have the same
degree as p1 in either case you would
have an x to the third term you would
have a third degree polynomial but how
many zeros how many distinct unique
zeros does p2 have pause this video and
think about that
well let's just list them out
so
our zeros
well once again if x equals one
this whole expression is going to be
equal to zero so we have zero at x
equals one and we can see that our white
graph also intersects the x-axis at x
equals one
and then if x is equal to three this
whole thing's going to be equal to zero
and we can see that it intersects the
x-axis at x equals three
and then notice this next this next part
of the expression would say oh well we
have zero at x equals three but we
already said that so we actually have
two zeros for a third degree polynomial
so something very interesting is
happening in some ways you could say
that hey it's trying to reinforce that
we have a zero at x minus three and this
notion of having multiple parts of our
factored form that would all point to
the same zero that is the idea of
multiplicity so let me write this word
down
so multiplicity
multiple
i'll write it out there and i will write
it over here
multiplicity
and so for each of these zeros we have a
multiplicity of one they're only they're
only deduced one time when you look at
it at factored form only one of the
factors points to each of those zeros so
they all have a multiplicity of one
for p2 the first zero has a multiple of
one only one of the expressions points
to a zero of one or would become zero if
x would be equal to one
but notice out of our factors when we
have it in factored form out of our
factored expressions
or our expression factors i should say
two of them become zero when x is equal
to three
this one and this one are going to
become zero and so here we have a
multiplicity of two
and i encourage you to pause this video
again and look at the behavior of graphs
and see if you can see a difference
between the behavior of the graph when
we have a multiplicity of one versus
when we have a multiplicity of two
all right now let's look through it
together we can look at p1 where all of
the zeros have a multiplicity of one and
you can see every time we have a zero we
are crossing the x-axis not only are we
intersecting it but we are crossing it
we're crossing the x-axis there we're
crossing it again and we're crossing it
again
so at all of these we have a sign change
around that zero
but what happens here well on the first
zero that has a multiplicity of one that
only makes one of the factors equal zero
we have a sign change just like we saw
with p1 but what happens at x equals 3
where we have a multiplicity of 2.
well there we intersect the x axis still
p of 3 is 0 but notice we don't have a
sign change we were positive before and
we are positive after we touch the
x-axis right there but then we go back
up
and the general idea and i encourage you
to test this out and think about why
this is true
is that if you have an odd multiplicity
and let me write this down if the
multiplicity is odd
so if it's 1 3 5 7 etc then you're going
to have a sign change
sign
change
while if it is
even as the case of two or four or six
you're going to have no sign change
no
sign
no sign change
one way to think about it in an example
where you have a multiplicity of two so
let's just use this zero here where x is
equal to three
when x is less than three
both of these are going to be negative
and a negative times a negative is a
positive and when x is greater than 3
both of them are going to be positive
and so in either case you have a
positive so notice you saw no sign
change
another thing to appreciate is thinking
about the number of zeros relative to
the degree of the polynomial
and what you see is is that the number
of zeros number of zeros
is at most equal to the degree of the
polynomial so it is going to be less
than or equal to
the degree
of
the polynomial
and why is that the case well you might
not all your zeros might have a
multiplicity of one in which case the
number of zeros is equal is going to be
equal to the degree of the polynomial
but if you have a zero that has a higher
than one multiplicity well then you're
going to have fewer distinct zeros
another way to think about it is if you
were to add all the multiplicities that
that is going to be equal to the degree
of your polynomial